so last week our producers suggested a
story on golf i said i hunt and fish i
know anything about golf and they said
no it's actually really interesting and
it is interesting there's a new league
called live golf
competing with the pga tour
so we decided to go down to trump
bedminster trump national golf club in
bedminster new jersey this weekend to
learn more about it and we showed you
part of our visit last night we had a
conversation with the new commissioner
of live golf greg norman one of the
greatest players in the world but we
wanted to know what the players who are
participating in live golf think of this
and why did they leave the pga anyway
why would anyone leave the pga well
bryson deschambeau is one of the best
golfers in the world played at smu he's
one of the longest drivers in the
history of the sport he's now playing
for liv he's got a really interesting
personal story too so we sat down with
him and asked him lots of golf-related
questions here's part of what he said
you spent six years on the pga tour yeah
you were one of the best young players
in college
how did you wind up here
this is a controversial choice according
to a lot of people definitely a lot of
opportunity um that was the first and
foremost thing
there was a new opportunity to do
something different in the game of golf
i've always been a bit of a trendsetter
when i was growing up i always
thought that i'd do something cool in
the game of golf i didn't know what it
would be
now that i see this i know this is a big
part of it
and the reason i say that is because
i've always thought that golf
has to start to tailor to the younger
generation if we want to continue to
grow the game i'm all about growth in
the game of golf and i think that as
time has gone on
this opportunity with live golf the way
it's structured from an investment
perspective
also from a a enjoyment perspective an
entertainment perspective all has a
possibility to do things that uh the
game of golf has never seen before
when you talk to people about live
they suggest that there's been a
violation of some kind of unspoken honor
code in golf or you're going to change
the culture
of golf and make it more vulgar
more populist
less honorable
i know you hear versions of that i'm not
sure i'm describing it exactly right but
the spirit of golf is being spirited
somehow
despoiled or desecrated by this how do
you respond to that
well a spirit of golf look i think
that in every industry no matter what it
is it's always been changing
innovating right and golf i don't think
is anything different
over the course of time if we want to
continue to grow the game or make the
game more interesting
if you're going to keep it with hickory
shafts and up a lot of ball and
you know no technology
people are not going to be interested by
that we've got to find ways to make it
more interesting whether it's
you know a new format
teams
that's personally one of my favorite
things about lip lip golf is the team
aspect no i think it's enhancing the
spirit of the game so pga tour is saying
that anyone who participates and live
will be banned for life from pga yeah it
doesn't matter 28 are you worried about
that no no i think it'll get figured out
and then i personally know that it will
get figured out whether it's legally or
whether they come to the table and work
out terms i definitely think it'll it'll
all wash itself out in the future uh
pretty shortly
um but it's funny it's it's so weird
because it's like
let's use this as a reference i heard
this earlier this week
you have a pizza shop that's been in
existence for 50 years and all the
customers go to it's a great product all
of a sudden a new pizza shop opens up
right and they start paying the
customers to come eat at their place and
that pizza is potentially a little bit
better of a of a pizza right
and then all of a sudden that original
pizza house goes if you go over there
we're banning you from member coming
back to our you know pizza shop what's
wrong with that economic model
that does seem short-sighted yeah
particularly if you have been the only
pizza shop in town if you've had a
monopoly correct that's probably not
allowed correct but there is this vibe
in golf it's more than a vibe it's a
kind of stated
ethic where you know it's not really
about the money or you should play for
free or
well in that case it just becomes a
hobby
yeah
we're playing for free i mean there's
our livelihoods and you know there's a
there's a great economic opportunity for
golfers to make a lot of money i mean
that's why we grew up playing golf also
for the history to go win majors and win
pga tour events initially and now i'm
out here i want to win live events i
mean you see the passion and competitive
aspect of this environment out here and
we all want to compete to win every
single week you know anytime anyone
invests over a billion dollars into
let's say the game of golf how is that
not going to grow the game how is that
not going to provide more opportunities
what is your parents your friends your
caddy you know
what did they all say well when we
looked at the economics it was solely
for the economics it was a no-brainer
considering the relationships i've built
with my sponsors considering
the relationship i have with the tour
the relationship i have with with uh my
competitors out there on tour as well i
had to think about all of that and how
that affected my livelihood moving
forward in the future and i had to wait
does the pros outweigh the cons and for
me from a financial perspective resource
allocation perspective meaning like i'm
able to do things now in dallas
and i think we can get to that in a
little bit
but i had to wait all those consequences
show a social consequence how i was
going to be viewed publicly i've got a
youtube channel now that's growing and
doing very well and want to continue to
produce product
there so i can showcase entertainment
and my skill set uh on that platform as
well you are well known for for bringing
science to golf yeah give us an example
wow well there's a lot of examples one
of them that i can think of directly off
the top of my head
this is more statistics but hitting it
farther has been a big notion of mine
and the reason i did that was because i
knew that if i could gain
three more yards off the tee
i could get i could be six more yards
offline so three more yards right or
left
and still
have a positive strokes gained
uh potential and what that means is that
i'm gaining shots on the field and so
from that perspective i took it on to me
how do i hit it farther how do i
consistently hit it farther how do i get
my body stronger what do i do from a
biomechanics perspective to make my golf
swing more repeatable so i'll go on
gears and try and understand how my
biomechanics are moving
in order to be the most repeatable and
powerful athlete i can possibly be so
how do you do that
a lot of studying data trying to
understand and crunching numbers start
trying to understand
how to create flat spots in the golf
swing this is getting really technical
now
please do okay uh trying to create flat
spots on the golf swing where you're
making a
combined motion that allows the golf
club to move in a very consistent
straight manner yeah it's not this
arcing manner that you're very sensitive
to air on you're trying to become less
sensitive to air so when i'm able to
like wrap around the corner this club is
going down
but because i'm going up it's actually
planing out and it goes straight into
the ball so your angle of attack's more
consistent you're lofted impact your
dynamic lofted impacts more consistent
so you're hitting
your spots a lot more consistently
meaning that your launch angle is going
to be consistent your spin rate's going
to be consistent and your landing
distance is going to be way more
consistent so you're doing calculations
in your head as you
yeah yeah we can't use uh green's books
which have a topographical map of the
putting green tells me exactly oh this
is 2.3 slope so we get i i know on
average what a 2 slope looks like a 3
slope looks like it's not me doing math
in my head i just have
memorized all the numbers do you count
cards in blackjack uh no i could but i
don't want to go down that route road i
don't want to get in trouble
that's totally fair but in golf you're
allowed to do this correct trying to
find a distinct advantage to help
benefit the game of golf in a positive
way and help my life out in the most in
the best way possible
amazing and as it paid off
well do you think it's paid off well it
sounds like it has i think it has for me
i'm very blessed i'm very lucky my
family's um very very happy
my friends around me are very happy i
know i'm now able to do things back in
dallas give back to my community in
dallas
building i'm going to build a
multi-sport complex center there attach
an education center there attach my
charity to it my charity bryson chamber
foundation supports junior golf health
and it's going to build an education
center i want to build an education
center without got an idea and model for
that i think will help benefit the
education system in general
so the resources that i now have doesn't
mean that i'm able to just sit on my
butt and and do nothing
i've got more responsibility now to take
care of my community my country
and my state
as much as i possibly can and at a
certain point in time you go man there's
more to life than just golf and that's
what live golf allows me to do i mean
i'm able to play golf and enjoy and
compete with some of the best players in
the world
but also have a life outside of this
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight